you did Rock de belles well rock the
bells came out I was like what the [ __ ]
is this you guys don't understand what
you were doing to us in Virginia
[Music]
[Music]
thankful to be here all good
very so what you've been listening to
lately anything exciting but for the
most part you know I just like to be
intrigued so tell me what intrigued
looks like for you intrigued for me is
first of all this moment is intriguing
doing this with you right now that's
intriguing but for me musically I feel
like I'm not I'm not one of those guys
that are like you know oh this is a 98
time signature this is amazing that just
feels like math to me I think I get
blown away by chord progressions that
make me feel something I've never felt
before like to me chords are coordinates
you know mean they like send you to a
place beautiful and when I'm lucky
enough to be in the right elevator
you know I'm looking up and I'm doing -
I'm doing three things at once I'm going
what is that mm-hmm number two I'm
trying to like remember the feeling
because when I go to chase it later that
is I'm gonna have to reverse-engineer
the feeling in order to get to the chord
structure and third to just back it up
by
trying to Shazam it right then and there
how great is Shazam Shazam is a gift
yeah game-changer game-changer so if you
find one what do you do with it let's
say you hear something in that moment
you have that experience you've Shazam
dit yeah next what happens I just want
to listen to it over and over and over
again and really understand what I'm
feeling and why I feel that way because
there's a there's a there's a hold like
University of Science between what's
being played and what you're hearing yes
so you're analyzing yourself as much as
the music yeah because if you don't then
you don't really you're not really
getting the proper assessment of what's
happening you know if I'm hearing
something but I'm not paying attention
to how I'm feeling then for me I don't
know what I'm listening that's my way of
that's my GPS of understanding that's
how I process things is how I feel
mm-hmm that everything is catalogued by
and categorized by the feeling of it if
I can't if I can't see how I feel about
it and I don't even really know what it
is it's just music so just give me you
don't have to give me a specific example
but what would be the kind of things
that you'd be on the elevator that would
stop you in your tracks you gain enough
to be specific but how would you
describe what you're hearing I'll take
it outside of music turns it's kind of
like being at a table with several
people you're in a conversation with
someone and all of a sudden you realize
you've drifted off and thought and this
person is still talking you hear their
voice but you now no longer know what
they're saying yes because you don't
you're not connected to you're not
you're not plugged in
yes to the conversation yes so now it's
just a bunch of vocal tone yeah that's
what it's like if I'm not if my feeling
is not connected to the song then I
don't really know what I'm listening to
couldn't really tell you what it was
when you're working on music with other
artists are you always working on it
with them in mind are you working on
your favorite music and then depending
on who you're collaborating with it
applies to it may or may not apply to
them I'm always channeling other people
usually the person that I'm working with
I'm sort of channeling them other times
I think that they should be channeling
someone else so I'll do that for them
and they may not suspect it it will
sound good on them 60% of the time they
don't do it 40% of the time people just
trust and try it
mm-hmm and within that 60% of the time
it goes to someone else who absolutely
gets it mm-hmm that's how the universe
works yeah like there are all these
triggers and not all of the ending
results will be what you think it's
supposed to be it's way that's what was
written yes if your speaks a little bit
to something you just said if you're
working with an artist and you have a
difference of opinion
with the artist over something you're
working on what what would normally
happen oftentimes I take off my ego hat
when I'm in the studio so a lot of times
there's this thing that happens where
it's like people respect for the most
part like sometimes most most people
assume like people respect others that
they idolize
but I found that people while sudden
they do sometimes but I found that
people really respect the person that
they kind of feel like is the Alpha in
the in their report and this new family
poor but most producers they kind of
like no I'm the Alpha like you know I
used you nominate records I've sold yeah
when troop Ito we've not sold anything
we've only made music and people chose
to stream it and share it and buying
whatever we're not responsible for it
our success there's degree millions of
people who are responsible absolutely
yeah but when you do that like
oftentimes you run the risk of them just
all of a sudden just being like man I
went from like trembling my boots
talking to my parents about being so
excited to be at the room with this guy
to like he you know I run the show
and so when we get to that place that
you're talking about when there's a
subtle disagreement this is what I have
to I don't I still leave my ego hat like
hung up at the door but that's when I
say you know maybe you should try this
so you know what if you do that it's
probably gonna be what you've been doing
and my job is to nudge you to poke and
prod and pull you and places that you
would not go so that you can get a
different result because if you do the
same things you're just gonna make
another one of those really well mm-hmm
you don't I'm saying and that's when
they have to trust you and that's that
same kind of very subtle trust of when
someone says oh you snore in your sleep
but you but you're one of those people
that doesn't snore and wake yourself up
you just snoring a certain hour or
whatever you just don't know yes you you
know it's one of those subtle things
that you just gotta trust that someone
sees something that you can't see yes
another example of what those subtleties
is like you hear yourself talk all day
and then you hear yourself when
voice smelling you sound completely
completely different and you hate what
you hear right
but everybody else hears the same thing
yes but you hate that
yes well the difference is is because
we're listening through the cavity of
our head but there again these people
who don't notice those subtle
differences they rule that out so if
they can trust you enough yes to know
that you can see hear or feel something
that is way too close for them to
discern then you guys have the
ingredients great ingredients for like
something new to come yes how often
would you say that happens is it typical
on most projects or once in a while or
once in a blue moon every time I go on
with Kendrick he transforms but he gets
that he knows he's his next man he's
super clear about that Arianna trusted
jamesy gets it he's always gotten it I
mean he's people don't realize he's been
making records since the 80s that's
unheard of what's the first record you
made with him got a lot of records
together I think it was given to me I
think that was the first one let's say
you were going into the studio tomorrow
with the new artist you never worked
with before what would a typical first
day be like is there a typical first day
it's what they come in talking about
it's what they happen to be actually
going through so what they're talking
about at that particular moment it's
what they happen to be going through and
it's a new way that I can use their
voice like a juxtaposition to what they
usually do like if we were comparing
their voice voices to textures if they
had a like satin voice what would it
sound like against granite versus you
know cotton you know if they have like a
crazy like diamond voice what does this
sound like you know dropped in jello
like how do i mix the sensory how I mix
the sensories together usually when you
start a project you come in with any
ideas or thoughts before it starts or do
you start with like a blank slate a lot
of times I'll come in with like two or
three ideas it might those be conceptual
ideas or tracks tracks
do you make tracks often yeah and do you
make tracks regardless of thinking about
where they're gonna go
sometimes I think about where they're
gonna go to get them out too late just
to make them yeah I have to channel yeah
i channel all the time I'm always
pretending I'm someone else in order to
get it to come out because I just feel
like I'm the best version of myself is
as a producer is I'm like a mirror for
people I try to show them sides of
themselves that they don't ever use as
like when people take selfies they only
take bite they only use like one side
all the time so I'm the guy who's like
hey you know God made another side like
it's very interesting you should try it
let's come up with a hypothetical
example name an artist you like from
childhood someone you listen to as a kid
can you tell me someone Stevie Wonder
okay so if you were producing a Stevie
Wonder album what would be what's what
would be your first instincts in making
a Stevie Wonder project that you would
want to listen to what would it be
that's kind of difficult because he's
done so many different genres
I mean his reggae was amazing his disco
was amazing his ballads were
unbelievable his Parisian Burt Bacharach
you know bossa nova' stuff was amazing
so maybe use some maybe let's use
somebody else okay I guess I only like
eclectic people
because I was gonna say Earth Wind and
Fire but like they did a lot of
chemicals absolutely I like a couple of
non eclectic groups
I like the Ramones and I wouldn't want
them to be different yeah they were
really good at that thing yeah yeah but
more often than not I like the watching
the evolution and growth maybe Prince
that's a good one so what would what
would the Pharrell produced Prince
project what would be different about it
maybe be interesting to hear him do like
afro-cuban be incredible be something
else yeah great idea beyond Stevie and
Prince who would have been the music you
listened to growing up earth one if I
James Brown and you grew up in a musical
household they played a lot of music all
the time brothers and sisters yes music
was just like in our environment it was
just like in the environment and like
going to church all the time you know
like between getting in the car and
listening to the music in the car listen
to the music at home and at church like
it was always something you grew up in
Virginia yes sir and what was the music
you listen to in the car
what was the station on the FM side it
was k94 and am side I was am 850 and
everything from Rick James give it to me
too
thriller to another one bites the dust -
[Music]
Chuck Brown's bustin loose I mean it was
a wide range
it just wasn't much good did gogo make
it to Virginia oh my goodness really
gogo was the second sound of Virginia
Wow
it was everything Wow everything do you
ever go to the go-go nothing like it
nothing like it that's a world yeah
and it's so interesting to me because
it's such a pocket that if you go
outside of DC North North wise like to
New York like you wouldn't know anything
about it no if you go but when you go
down south you can find some of it in
Delaware you could find a little bit of
it in Maryland but not much and and
Virginia was just big and the Carolinas
it was big it was a world it's a world
when I first heard it completely blew my
mind completely it felt like it was the
next like after hip hop the next wave it
felt like that yeah I felt like that
well you guys produce that out of
Records with that sound yeah right yeah
you did rock DuBose
I haven't heard it in a while but hope
it holds up that's crazy bro
I was I never forget where I was when I
heard rock the bells for the first time
we were over my cousin's house out in
Norfolk and uh I got a cousin named Fifi
and my mom and dad used to go over their
house over the weekends that were like
we would just go over there to play
cards well they would go at it play
cards I don't know how today we'll play
like spades and but when Rock the Bells
came out I was like what the [ __ ] is
this the because it was because we love
gogo yeah so it was kind of like these
New York guys which is like go-go sound
and then like L was like the coolest had
the crazy chains you guys don't
understand what you were doing to us in
Virginia it was a whole thing it was
like you know yeah I bad I wanted a
troop jacket like how bad I wanted a
troop jacket I wanted that I wanted
those chains the music just literally
transformed it was doing things to our
minds shifting our perspectives making
us dance making us run to the television
to watch you on TV wraps for a glimpse
of anything yeah any kind of slang we
savored it yeah
because those records were so good
people don't remember how hard it was to
hear rap music no it was the underground
of the underground yes it was a tiny
subculture really tiny but he's super
huge yes but also timing yeah like they
like they did a lot to try to suppress
it but the white kids loved it too much
and there was no hate to make it racial
but that's what changed it right
we've been professed our love for it you
guys been making it but you just
couldn't you know they couldn't suppress
that it just was too big it was just too
strong it was too beautiful and it was
igniting people in a way why do you
think they wanted to suppress it they
don't understand it
in my opinion they didn't understand it
they didn't understand what was coming
from if you don't understand where it's
coming from you really don't understand
why it's necessary to support it and
then like some a group of people
realized there was a lot of money in it
and then things changed obviously mmm I
think it changed for the worst
personally my experience was when people
started getting involved once they saw
they could make money in it yeah it
changed the culture a little bit sure is
early on anyone who's doing it clearly
loved it because there was no upside so
if you were doing it you had to love it
yeah you just did it because it felt
amazing that's it what's here what's
your first memory of any hip-hop
craftworks Wow interesting
I wouldn't have given that answer even
though probably same but I wouldn't have
thought that yeah yeah we were hearing
those records and we were like what is
this another record it was very
transformative in Virginia was strafe
set it off yeah incredible one of the
greats any time we were to club and that
came on people just lost their mind
one of the greats and there's not much
to it if you think back every sound yeah
every sound that's all yeah that's like
what I was like trying to beat when we
did grind and I was like trying to beat
like the classic Miss of like set it off
I mean the Benjamins is what sent sent
us in the studio like okay we gotta like
we gotta beat this yeah but set it off
was like set it off was a hit for like
eight more years yeah for sure for sure
you can go out to a club today and still
hear it and it would play like it played
the day came out starts with one snare
there was as a kid
there was nothing like coming outside
somebody pulling up like you know their
car whatever you come outside and like
one of the drug dealers is like you
don't have the system light just
knocking and then plants set it off and
they all just sitting around like
smoking a joint and you're just like
these guys are Titans I mean that's how
we looked at them they were like
larger-than-life fear I mean every time
you came outside you know the gold
chains or whatever whatever and the
music's playing
those are videos at least that's how I
was looking at it I will just go outside
like wow we're losers well what we're
gonna do today
let's go loose squawk outside and you
just see like the baddest chicks you
know the hoop earrings the bicycle
shorts you know with the incredible
figures talking to the drug dealers and
those guys are all just like you know
chains out passing joints and set it off
as playing and it's a movie another
record to me that is like had like a
eight year run white lines yeah how are
you just like how do they just like nail
each one of Planet Rock mm-hmm numbers
set it off and white lines and Anam the
message mm-hmm each one of those records
so my question is like how like what
were those guys feeling where was
Grandmaster Flash and melly-mel feeling
when they made a message I might argue
Scorpio for that matter
up there Scorpio yeah so knows DJ and
how to always play Scorpia did you did
you do that record to what L I don't
know the jingling baby no that's after
me okay
because that's what he sample oh is it
yeah no idea yeah that was a rocket yeah
Bam Bam Bam pi PI pi PI pi PI pi PI pray
so cool that's like music was a
different kind of eclectic then any
theories why technology where it was
where it was instrumentation was still
very much so a very big part of it
there's a lot of predictive default
modes in in the way that people program
now yeah like so you don't have to play
as much as you can you know it's perfect
for someone who is a great player or
someone who's not the best player but
has ideas has really strong ideas so
that takes a lot of the experimentation
that the Machine can predict and get to
but there's a different thing that man
has that the machines don't it's an
intuitive this yes an intuitive
intuition and prediction are two
different things and so the machine can
do give you a bunch of predictive
equations for examples of changes you
might like or things you might want to
do and make some really very interesting
suggestions but it's predictive and it's
pretty much based on like not even
random but just like different
variations
whereas intuition is like no go
completely left mm-hmm how much do you
rely on technology like
are you attached to certain instruments
or certain technology I think I'm like
pretty much porous at this point like
I'm just open you know I like the way I
work at the moment but I'm like open to
ya new methods when you first started
making music you went from not seeming
like a hip-hop fan into what's the first
thing you ever made regardless whether
you put it out or not what was your
first experiments in making your own
music we chat and I and I and I haven't
mentioned chat yet but because I think
you asked me a lot of questions in
reference to my own personal process but
for a very big part of my career Chad
and I work together and I think what we
tried to do and we still work together
yeah but I think for the most part what
we always tried to do was
reverse-engineer the songs that did
something to us emotionally and figure
out where the mechanism is and there and
listen said to you before try to figure
out if we can build a building that
doesn't look the same but makes you feel
the same way yeah I did that and blurred
lines and got myself in trouble yeah
that ridiculously Stevie Wonder told me
he said you got to get the right
musicologists in there because juries
don't understand it's very technical
what you've done yeah and it's the song
is nothing like the song nope but the
feeling was
yeah but the feeling is a nice eye thing
that you can copyright know you can't
copyright a feeling y'all salsa songs
sound pretty much the same yes and
reggae songs or any genre 100% rap music
sounds relatively similar yeah but
here's the difference yeah what we
failed and it hurt my feelings because I
would never take anything from anyone of
course
and I really set me back I made Missy
Elliott's where they from in the middle
of that trial when I was really hurt
because what I realized all too late was
what he was trying to tell me is I
needed to use what it used my gift to
make music to reverse-engineer the the
disparity between the truth and people's
and the juries uneducated opinions and I
say that because rayon and silk feel the
same when we understand that there's a
clear difference yeah
and that was what what happened like I'm
really made it feels so much like it
yeah that people were like oh I hear the
same thing yeah and it's like no yeah
look at the notes yeah well you don't
know then you know when you get like you
know an ambulance chaser which is who
they got it's got another one in like
let me not speak negatively about them
this was my lesson yeah I didn't take
Stevie's advice to the fullest extent I
did I thought I was but I never I really
underestimated people are not not
getting that yeah but the the issue is
it it's bad for me it's bad for music
because we've we've had an understanding
of what a song is and now based on that
one case now there's a question what
it's all is yeah it's not what it used
to be
because in the past it would be the
chords the melody and the words would be
the song mm-hmm and your chords your
melody and your words none of them had
anything to do No
so it was just a feeling but if I don't
then you see what he's you know it
leaves us as music makers in a really
uncomfortable place making things
because now we don't know what you can
do I failed you
I did I left it up to what I thought
would be you know what was right yeah
what I was wrong because I didn't go to
the extra mile to get people to
understand you can't you can cop you can
copyright that which is tangible yes not
the intangible yes and that's what they
proved yes because I had a ability to
make something feel very similar yes
they said you know what this is wrong if
it feels like it that's what it is
well you can't copyright a feeling
because if that's the case there will be
a lot of marijuana cases right now right
well this weed makes me feel this way
and this weed makes me feel this way
it's the same copywriting feeling yeah
right so that means that like if you
make chocolate and somebody else makes
chocolate and both of them make someone
feel a certain kind of way they can now
sue you be an interesting documentary
for you to make about just about this
just explain just explain to people how
it works what you did what the what the
rules historically have been and what
impact this this decision has on the
history of music because if you I mean
everything is rooted in something
everything
yeah that won't that won't hurt me that
one set me back that one like that hurt
well everyone was shocked by it of
course anyone who knows about it
who knows who understands the situation
would be shocked by it because what you
did was completely what has been done
since the beginning of people making
music yeah I mean can you imagine all
the people who made Motown esque music
everyone you know yes everybody that
makes many in gay yes everybody that
makes jazz yeah Oh without swinging hey
this is interesting I never really made
this connection before but I wonder if
this in any way plays into the the new
way our culture is looking back on
material like I was at a dinner the
other night and someone mentioned that
Richard Pryor wouldn't be able to put
out the material that he put out today
and Richard Pryor was great you know one
of the great all-time greats and I
wonder if there's this like if the line
of what's possible instead of it being
this ever expanding growth of making
more beautiful interesting things the
powers that be may be very much like in
the beginning bidding beginning days a
hip-hop are trying to constrict that
that opening of what's possible to share
I mean there's a there's a yeah I think
there's I think there's always that
anyways I mean I think that's the
country we live in that's the world we
live in there's always a bunch of
you know older folks who are and
positions of power who don't think as
progressively as the younger generation
and seek to hold things and keep trying
to keep things as yesterday when we
already know it's already for tomorrow
I mean I don't think that he could do
that kind of I don't think that he could
do it now
I don't think Richard could do it now I
think he's amazing he's demeans to go
he's did like the greatest of all time
to me yeah of all the time yeah but I
don't think you could because the polls
have shifted already and when the polls
shift everything in the matrix it's just
a new new it's a new color it's a new
taste it's the new smells and new
feeling and the rules change if you go
back and look at half the commercials
that were like out in the 70s like they
are incredibly disrespectful to women
like incredibly and so he made his jokes
were created and at a time when the
zeitgeist was progressive for that time
mm-hmm but then when you look over your
shoulder you realized that even in you
know the need to progress was still so
much super wrong [ __ ] I mean like
LGBTQIA where they were like really not
even allowed to exist with the exception
of being mocked as man cross-dressing
for a joke or cross-dressing for a show
other than that that just didn't happen
and they you know it was okay to call
them names and be incredibly
disrespectful to people's feelings that
would never that will never fly
but he I mean if you really know his
life story like I mean he didn't have
anything against anyone
no and maybe and maybe he could have for
that reason yeah
but the language that he used was
because it was pushing it for that time
yes it was of the moment you can't you
can't you can't take art out of the
context in which it was made
yeah an art is expression and the art of
art you know the power of art but what
gives art its pertinent is when people
are pushing it yeah he would be pushing
it in a completely different way work
right now but but the world was a
different place so he would be pushing
it maybe in the same way but it would
feel completely different in today's
world because the world's different yeah
so the context would change everything
yes but he would it would be the same
velocity yes of power the same degree
probably just different jokes 100% yeah
since since the blurred lines issue it's
interesting I was even gonna bring it up
but since since because we was talking
about feeling yeah I know that's my dad
I know that's what the universe is
giving me funny thing is giving me is
like the ability is to make things is to
reverse-engineer a feeling make a
tangible item so since what happened
happened has it changed anything about
the way you work no good this is the
only way I know how to make great yeah
that's great news yeah I just know I
need to be incredibly when something
feels super no matter if the chords are
absolutely like they're jazz chords yeah
and and what I am seeking to match the
feeling in is like a tease power power
band cool chords I still reach out hey
you guys just want to be clear this
feels the same to me yeah but it's not
yeah yeah
here's this here's this here's this
here's this how do you feel about this
you know just how
those kinds of conversations if there's
someone who's just like completely
outlandish about something like alright
I'm cool on you like whatever which
never happens this was just like a freak
situation absolutely that was meant to
Humble me to teach me a lesson and I
think that lesson was just be very clear
and what my intentions are and to just
not assume that everybody understands
the difference the difference between
rayon and silk yeah I'm a rayon yes he
may sell yes sometimes you want rayon
yeah
depends what pens on the use yeah
there's there's a reason rayon exists
what's the most fun or exciting moment
for you in the process when you make
something and you're like yeah I gotta
play this again you know only a couple
times in my career I made something like
that where me and my wife would just
play it over and over and over going to
ride and we'll look up and we've been
driving for like 45 to an hour a couple
times it's a great feeling
oh my goodness yeah I love the moment
when we're working in the studio
patiently you know waiting for something
to happen yeah and something goes from
not so interesting to really interesting
and not much changed yeah and it's like
what just like what happened what just
happened and it's a little scary that
feeling of like didn't nobody move well
it's very exciting and it's so it's so
out of our control you know can't make
that happen no it's just patience no
I don't think we make we don't make much
happen when it comes to creativity we're
just we're just antennas and transistors
yes
we're speakers you know we're just lucky
to get the transmission yeah when did
your interest in fashion begin Oh ever
since I realized I didn't have it and I
was young and while other friends would
come to class with like Jordans and all
these are the things I would always say
they and I I get those and I would like
see those in green you know and so when
given an opportunity I just started like
doing it just because I was so
appreciative to be able to do it do you
see it as the same as making music
making yeah yeah yeah same it's the same
you're using the same same process yeah
definitely using the same muscles
anything else you'd be interested in
applying those muscles to that you
haven't yet well first of all like the
one thing that's definitely on my mind
before I leave is that we have to do
something together you don't need me I
definitely need you I'm not sure for
what yet I don't know what you're
working on but I mean I'm so down you're
like we'll find something important to
do together I would be so honored you
talked about you and Chad starting
together making music how would you say
the process of making music has changed
from before doing anything starting as a
kid being a fan making music till now
what's changed I guess being a family
man you know
more than more of a family man than I
ever was I always said that I was gonna
have like four kids I didn't know I was
really gonna have four kids I always
said it yeah and we went from one to
four incredible that's the only
difference I love music music is like
music is the is the key that's open you
know it's the skeleton key that's open
every door for me including this one
right here
who knew on the other side of court
structures that would make me emotional
as a child would lead to this moment
right here I go on the other side of
listening to you know q-tip sample and
Roy Ayers music productions daylight to
make Benita alpha bum on the other side
of my infatuation with that song and
listening to it over and over again on
repeat on the other side of that of
those chords was the distance to this
moment nothing's changed all built on
music hundred percent the mountain of
song it's crazy yeah yeah we're very
lucky that this bit we get to play in
this world so much yeah I mean I want
this for everybody I want everybody to
wake up every day going how did that how
did this happen I love doing this I feel
like I get paid for free so I'm doing
what I love to do
I want that for everybody this is this
place is amazing
this interview was you know awesome just
so grateful so grateful for this
opportunity to be able to sit with you
and that's look I'm to me that's how
awesome the universe is you know what
I'm saying
absolutely we are blessed I got a chance
to sit and talk to you the unit like the
universe were set out that way but
you're doing one thing okay and you're
also gonna sit down and have this
conversation thank you for making the
long journey out here
they're trying to silence the voices of
hip-hop